oh one two three
how the hell were you to know they
expected you to drive oh you were
halfway in a coma but you made it home
alive
[Music]
and it's a miracle babe that we got
anything left to piss away
well Father's Day had come and gone and
you forgot to call your mom and thank
her for the double shift the reason you
even exists well those were difficult
days
[Music]
that we got anything left to this
stuff don't you
cause how the hell were you to win try
surprise and have the skin well it was
rigged right from the jump you did your
best and hung it up it's easy difficult
times it's just a blind lead in The
Blind and it's a miracle anyone's
anywhere on time that's right
[Music]
thank you
it's a miracle babe save for one or two
good days that we got anything left to
fish
it's a miracle hey it's a miracle
these are difficult days
every time you walk outside don't you
know that you could die I guess it's
always been that way and it's a miracle
foreign
[Applause]